[Music]
dear friends your vote is precious
almost sacred it is the most powerful
nonviolent tool we have to create a more
perfect union that was Congressman John
Lewis speaking at the important speaking
of the importance of the vote at the
2012 Democratic National Convention in
Charlotte North Carolina Lewis spent
much of his life fighting for voting
rights and was a champion of the Voting
Rights Act of 1965 it established
federal oversight of election laws in
states with a history of racial
discrimination the Supreme Court struck
down key sections of that legislation in
2013 and as ed O'Keefe reports Lewis had
been pushing to restore parts of the law
ever since the bill is passed without
objection Congressman John Lewis banging
the gavel on a vote last December
reinstate parts of the Voting Rights Act
laid on the table a bill first passed in
1965 in part because of his march in
Selma Alabama the scene of violence
against black protesters demanding
voting rights horrified Americans
months later Lewis was there when
President Lyndon Johnson signed the Act
into law the President of the United
States Lyndon Johnson members of the
House and Senate and American people
heard our cries and responded to our
pain and tough suffering the Voting
Rights Act was renewed several times
most recently in 2006 with bipartisan
support but in 2013 the US Supreme Court
invalidated federal oversight of
elections a key part of the law designed
to keep tabs on states with a history of
discriminating against minority voters
the court decided such oversight was no
longer necessary because of changes made
by States since 1965 Lewis strongly
disagreed and became the lead advocate
for fully restoring the law they're
saying in effect that history cannot
repeat itself
come and walk in my shoes
Vanita Gupta is headed a Leadership
Conference on civil and human rights a
group Lewis worked with to restore the
act the 2013 decision from the United
States Supreme Court devastated the
voting rights movement give me an
example of where it's still an issue
well voter suppression is alive and well
in the United States of America in 2020
so today we when you see on the news
these long long lines why do those long
lines exist and why do they only exist
in predominantly black and brown
communities but Senate Republicans have
refused to take up the issue of voting
rights arguing States should be left to
run their own elections just last week
Republican Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell told The Wall Street Journal
there's very little tangible evidence of
this whole voter suppression nonsense
that the Democrats are promoting but now
congressional Democrats say they'll be
stepping up pressure on Republicans the
best thing that Senate Republicans can
do to honor the legacy service sacrifice
and sincerity of congressman Lewis is to
pass that Voting Rights Act bill
congressman Jeffries and some of his
colleagues now say that if or when parts
of the Voting Rights Act are restored
the legislation doing so should be
renamed the John R Lewis voting rights
act but the realities of Washington are
such that unless Democrats have full
control of the White House in Congress
passage of that legislation is it
expected anytime soon
Tony all right thank you very much